- Thank you everyone for joining.
Very excited to talk about
the topic we have today,
which is about cracking the SMB code
and how United Airlines
has very successfully
been able to do that.
So as we have introduction,
my name is Kunal,
I am a principal at ZS,
and I help lead our travel
and hospitality practice.
And who better to talk about
this topic than with the person
who leads B2B marketing and
international marketing.
A lot of good stuff at United.
But before I take away
her introduction, Jane,
maybe any quick introduction
that you'd like to share?
- Sure.
- Sure, thanks Kunal, great to be here.
My fun fact is this is my
second time in Venice this week,
I actually was fortunate enough
to be in the real Venice
earlier this week.
Just got back on Friday, so I'm just kind
of hopping all over time zones.
So my name is Jane, I've been with United
for about six years.
I lead the B2B marketing
team as Kunal said,
and I have the pleasure
of launching this brand new capability
to address the SMB potential.
So really excited to
chat with you all today.
- Amazing, well, thank
you again for joining.
Thank you everybody for
joining us for this session.
So, Jane, let's start all the
way at the beginning, right?
Small and medium business is
of course a very attractive segment.
What did you guys see at United
that you thought, you know,
highlighted the opportunity
or the challenges that you were facing?
How did you embark on this?
Where did this journey start?
- Yeah, and it's funny,
it actually really started
to almost my very first day
at United Airlines six years ago in 2019.
And it was work that you
guys were kicking off.
One of the things we asked ZS
to do is give us the entire
landscape of the business travel
and the travel market in the US,
and help us understand
where we have opportunities.
And the number one opportunity,
of course, not surprisingly,
was the SMB space.
And what we saw is that we had really deep
and longstanding relationships with some
of the world's largest organizations,
but we had essentially
single digit penetration
with the small businesses, right?
And as we really dug into
that, we realized it's
because we didn't have a capability
to serve them profitably.
So that's really where it started,
very simply looking at the landscape
and identifying a white
space where we had really,
really low penetration.
- Yeah, and you know,
as you were speaking,
I was just looking out at folks,
and you know, you see a few nods here too.
I don't think it's uncommon
among any industries
to target and acquire small
and medium sized businesses.
Very hard to go after with
traditional sales forces,
because the ROI is just not there.
But of course now with the, you know,
with innovation in B2B marketing
and just martech more broadly,
we can actually do this
efficiently, effectively.
So as you embark on, as you
guys embarked on that journey,
can you talk a little bit
about how you used some
of what's available now to
win some of these customers?
- Yeah, absolutely, as we
went to build the story
of how we wanna go
after this opportunity, one of
the questions we knew we had
to answer is, What are we
gonna do differently this time?
Because it wasn't the first
time that United tried to go
after this opportunity,
as you can imagine.
In fact, we joked around at the time
that we still have United Business Go
as a registered trademark
for the last time
that we had tried it.
So it wasn't even that long
ago that we had failed,
and our competitors had also failed.
So the question that we
really asked ourselves,
What are we gonna do
differently this time?
And as I was building a
story, I realized it had
to be this idea that
it's not a technology,
it's an ecosystem that we had to build.
That's really around four parts.
The first part of the ecosystem
is of course the site itself,
a place for SMB customers to go
to sign up for their program.
The second piece was the
digital marketing capability
to drive them to the site,
and actually get them
to sign up and engage.
The third piece of it was the
data that was gonna allow us
to build our target list,
build our segmentations
off of those target lists,
and you know, actually
again, kind of attract them
through the digital marketing capability.
And finally, it was the team,
like we needed to actually have a team
to orchestrate all this.
It wasn't just building a portal
or building some sort of
system and push and go.
It really had to be a full ecosystem
of those four components.
And that's what I've been
preaching since that day
is it has to be all of
those four elements together
in order to build the right foundation
to scale this in the long term.
- Yeah, it's a great point.
And for those of you who
may not be as familiar
with the travel industry,
especially on the B2B side,
on the corporate travel side more broadly,
there's sort of two buyers, right?
There is the buyer that we call, you know,
a corporate travel manager
or the ones who decide to sign up
for a program with United, right,
for instance, or any other company.
And those could be for a small
business, could be a CEO,
it could be a CFO, it could
be a head of procurement,
it could even be a sort of
designated travel manager, right?
But then there's also the second
piece, which is the people
who actually travel, the end
travelers, all of us, right?
And those people,
so the way we like to, you know,
characterize it is you
gotta get on the shelf
and then you gotta get
picked off the shelf, right?
And I think, you know,
to win both those pieces,
like Jane said, you have to
win in B2B marketing, you have
to win in B2C marketing
'cause you get the, you know, you have
to have the end travelers pick you.
You have to have a dashboard
that allows you to manage the program
and even a.com capability
where you go to united.com say,
and you want all your fares
to sort of seamlessly appear
for you, your corporate rates
to pull through, and so on.
And of course technology is a big element.
Jane talked a little bit
about people and process,
and we'll talk about that in a second.
But Jane, can you talk a little bit more
about the technology?
'Cause United has done such
good stuff in enabling this,
and even allowing for this
sort of seamless experience,
and connecting all of these four pieces.
- Yeah, thank you.
Let me unpack that a bit,
'cause I think you've said some,
a lot of important things there.
So yeah, it's helpful to
understand our ecosystem,
and both the travel manager
and the travel that we're working with.
But as advice to all of
you, I'm sure not all
of you are in the travel industry.
I think the piece of advice
there is to think through
those layers of influence,
and understand when you need
to unlock that influencer
and with what particular message.
And that's exactly what
we did in our case, right?
When we're talking to the travel manager,
we're talking about savings
that they can deliver
for their company,
that maybe is not necessarily
the most relevant message
to the traveler, but to
the traveler manager,
that's what's important.
Some of the reporting tools
we offer on our portal
that's important to them, right?
So we sort of attract them
with the right messaging
to influence them to click that button
to get into the program.
But the journey doesn't
end there, as Kunal said.
And there's that second
layer of influencer,
the traveler actually has
to still book the trip,
and put that into their cart.
And that's where the technology
piece was really important.
We wanted that to be super simple.
So essentially, you just
link your work email address
to your business account,
and your discounts show up
automatically in your app, right?
So we wanted to leverage the existing B2C
and traveler ecosystem that
already exists at United.
So they book the exact same
way they've always booked.
They just kind of click
a business travel button
versus the personal travel button, right?
And we do have amazing technology,
if you guys are not United flyers,
we do have the number one app out there.
So I highly recommend (laughs)...
(Kunal laughs)
- Time to fly.
- First of all, flying United
and downloading the app if you haven't,
it's truly amazing and world class.
And again, as a traveler, we're not trying
to reinvent the wheel for you,
but you get those discounts,
you get access to all of
that program through the tools
and channels you already are using.
- Amazing, and so, you
know, I'm sure a lot
of folks here are thinking, you know,
as you talked about
technology, you know, take us
behind the scenes in terms
of maybe some of those,
I don't know, kinks, or you know, some
of the challenges you might have run into,
or some of the key success
factors as you were thinking
of executing on this technology, right?
What were some of those
learnings that you had?
I know, my opinion, you went
through this process, is
probably the most patient
and best in class way
of going through this.
- Oh, thank you.
- But may maybe you can
share a little bit more
with the audience in
terms of, you know, some
of those things that
don't make the newsreel.
- Yeah, no, absolutely, and
there's a lot of lessons there.
I'm sure there's some
things I'll share with you
that are not gonna be super surprising,
but it's amazing how you
can lose sight of it.
Number one is, again, it kind of goes back
to telling that story.
So we built the story, we
built an airtight story,
and we told it over and
over and over again,
I cannot tell you the number
of times I've presented the same slides
at different levels at organization.
I know it's not ideal, but obviously
United is a giant company,
a lot of us probably
work at giant companies,
but it's just being consistent
in the storytelling,
and at all levels and at
different parts of organization.
So by the time that we
got that funding approved,
everyone was bought in from the DT team
that was building the
technology, to the finance team
that was funding the technology,
to of course, the sales team
that was gonna implement this technology.
Everyone knew what it was.
And a slight nuance to this too
that I was actually
reflecting on recently,
we kind of internally branded this thing,
and I wasn't necessarily thinking
that's what we were doing,
but I realized that was a key, you know,
a key factor in our success.
We called it a small business
demand center, right?
We gave it a name that was
very clear, very definitive of
what it was, and it was
meant to be an internal name
to help define this new capability.
And every time I talked about it,
I talked about it's not a
technology, it's not a platform,
it's this new capability.
So I think that was another
key factor in the success.
And of course once we got
the funding, we kept telling
that story, and we continue
to tell the story of that success.
I would say the second factor is,
don't wait for all the pieces
to be perfectly in place to start, right?
We had to start somewhere, we, you know,
had really grand visions of
building four ML algorithms
that were gonna help us target
and segment the customers
and decide the next best action.
But the reality is, we weren't
gonna build all of them
and then start, right?
We had to start somewhere.
So also, the portal was gonna
have all this functionality,
but to be perfectly honest,
we are two years into the launch,
and we're still building
out that functionality.
But we had to start somewhere,
and we're slowly scaling,
slowly optimizing,
slowly tweaking.
And the beauty of that
approach is we now have
an installed user base of real customers
that are providing real-time feedback.
So we're not training
our algorithms on sort
of a hypothetical data that
we bought from a third party,
we're training it based on
what's actually happening,
and what our customers are actually doing.
And sure, we've had some learnings,
and I'll kind of talk
about it in our closing
and some of our improvements.
We've learned that what we went out with,
we went out with three options.
Well guess what?
People are, 90% of our customers,
are choosing one of those options.
So clearly, we, you know,
weren't as differentiated
or distinctive in those
options as we thought we were.
But I'm still so happy to be learning live
and have the ability to adapt,
because it is also giving
us the credibility to ask
for more funding and to ask
for additional investment,
because we can say that we're bringing
high quality incremental revenue,
and not just in our hubs,
from our spokes as well.
- You know, personally,
in just being a small part
of this journey with you guys,
I think one of the things
that stood out to me was the patience.
You know, the patience that
this is not a week long exercise
or a month long exercise
or even a few months,
it took a lot of fine
tuning of these algorithms
for the targeting to actually work.
You know, I know that
there were some, like,
you didn't see success immediately.
There was some success,
pockets of success,
but then you stayed the course.
It felt like leadership
and just cross-functional alignment,
and commitment to the cause
sort of was a key aspect.
I know it might sound theoretical,
but in reality that was important
as everyone believed in the outcome
and said, "Hey, let's stay the course,
and let's stick with it."
Is that a fair representation
of what happened?
- That's a really fair representation.
And my other piece of advice here
is be really clear on ultimately
what is that metric that
you're measuring, right?
So we did go out
and say, "Hey, finance give
us X amount of dollars,
and we're gonna give you 100 million,
bajillion dollars," right?
And at the end of the day,
we did not deliver on a year one number.
And we had to go in front of finance,
and we had to explain the conversation,
and it was actually one of the
best meetings I've ever had,
because we went into
that meeting saying we did
not hit our objectives.
But what really matters?
It's not the revenue
that's flowing through,
it's not the number of
accounts that we've signed up,
but it's the fact that these
are incremental customers
that are, what we call in
our business "high yield",
which, you know, just
means they paid a lot
of money for the plane ticket.
(chuckles) And so we focus on that metric
that we are bringing in high yield,
incremental revenue into the system.
That definitely still more than paid back
the investment that we made on the money.
So we didn't hit our goal in
terms of the number accounts,
we didn't hit our goal in
terms of the overall revenue.
But ultimately, what finance cares about
is high quality incremental revenue,
and we got that.
- So of course, I mean we're here
at re:Invent, technology is
obviously the cornerstone of
what happened here, but I
don't think it would be,
I think it would be unfair to say
that this was only a technology effort,
'cause I, at least just
from having seen this again,
from our lens, the team
that you had in place,
the operating model of
how you worked with
technology, revenue management,
other functions, just
overall there was much
more than just the technology.
You know, can you talk
a little bit about some
of those other enabling
factors for success?
- Yeah, absolutely.
In fact, one of the elements of our,
the funding that we asked for,
was a project we did with you guys
to help us build the team, to
write the job descriptions,
to write an operating model
of how this team was gonna work
within the broader organization.
And we still obviously
have fruit from that.
So that was a really
important part of it, right?
It wasn't just, we got this headcount,
and then we're done, we
wash our hands clean.
We really had to think about
how does this new team work
within the existing structure,
and what are those SOPs
that we're all aligned to.
And the other thing I would say is,
it's really, really important
to hire the right person
to lead that team, right?
There is, you know, a
very specific skillset
when you're launching something brand new.
That person has to be collaborative.
They also have to be
really comfortable working
in gray areas just in general,
I think that's the number one
thing I evaluate these days.
Like, are you able to work in gray area?
'Cause there's no more black
and white in this world.
So that was really important.
And someone who has an insane
amount of ownership, right?
Someone who's gonna break down
barriers and make it happen,
because it's really challenging.
It is really challenging,
especially when you start.
So that would be my other tip.
If you're building out a
new capability like this
to address SMB potential, be
really, really thoughtful of
who you put at the helm of
that kind of organization.
- That's right.
And she is great.
She knows who she is, but she's great.
And I do think overall
ownership of this program,
and you know, you talked
a little bit about SBDC
and the branding, but you know,
one of the things I've
I've heard you say is,
"Hey, it's not just a
technology, it's a capability."
It feels like this is one of those things
that all these three pieces have to sort
of work together for it to really-
- Four pieces, Kunal.
- All four pieces, four pieces,
but all the pieces have to work together
for this to really work well.
- Absolutely.
- Fantastic.
All right, so you know, we
have a few more minutes.
I was just looking at the time,
we have a few more minutes.
So, Jane, maybe if we can
close with what's next, right?
SBDC of course is yielding
tremendous value to United,
and targeting the right customers.
It's taken time, but you know,
you're of course hitting your stride now,
but I don't think we can walk
past a booth here without
talking about agentic AI,
or some of the innovations
that are on the horizon.
So maybe, can you share a little bit
about where SBDC goes from here?
- Yeah, absolutely, I can mention
of, you know, three things
that we're continuing to tweak on.
I already touched on a couple of them,
but I'll just expand on it.
Number one, like I said, we
did learn that the products
that we put out in front
of our customers did meet one
segment of the opportunity,
but missed a pretty big one.
And so we spent a lot of
time trying to address that.
So we've essentially satisfied the people
that are just wanting straight discounts
on their tickets, right?
They don't care about anything else,
I'm just trying to save the
bottom line for my company.
So we have a plan for that,
that's been really successful.
That's the one that 90% of our
customers are signing up for.
But there's a segment of
customers we're learning
that are really into the experience
and into the freebies, right?
So they wanna be earning the freebies
and the points that they
can redeem for free things.
And that was not something
that we had the technology
to build into the portal initially.
We had a feeling that was going
to be the case, to be honest,
'cause we clearly understand
our customers well,
but we also knew that technology-wise,
we weren't gonna be able
to launch in in time.
So we chose to launch with
a discount only program,
but having a pretty good
sense that we were gonna have
to do this follow-up work.
And that's exactly what we're doing.
And we just launched, we just
announced that we're going
to launch that phase of
the plan mid of next year
where our customers
will be able to sign up.
And they don't receive discounts,
but they slowly earn benefits
and rewards as they travel with United.
The other piece we talked about is
the algorithms, right?
We're continuing to build them out,
and now we're getting to a phase of it
where it's learning from
actual customer behavior,
which is really exciting,
versus kind of hypothetical data
that we're buying from a third party.
And the next algorithm we're working on is
that Next Best Action algorithm,
which is essentially going
to recommend a marketing action
to the digital marketing team for a lead
that's coming into the platform,
based on where they're coming from
and what they've engaged with
from a content standpoint to date.
And what we know from past
customers in terms of what drove
what was most likely to
drive the conversion, right?
So that algorithm is incredibly important,
and is the final algorithm
of what ZS had proposed
to us at that time, that we
are in the process of building.
And finally, of course,
you know, gen AI, we have
to talk about a chat bot.
We did introduce a chat
bot to the platform.
To be honest, we only have two individuals
that are servicing these
10,000 of customers
that are coming into our portal.
And so chat bot just
makes that more efficient.
But the chat bot is just as good
as the information we've put in it,
it's not generative, it's not very smart.
And so we are noticing
that things are escalating
to human quite often.
And so if we want to continue
to scale, we're gonna have
to improve the generative
abilities of that chat bot
to address more of the
questions that are coming in.
So again, we can continue to
scale with the size of the team
that we currently have.
So I would say those are
three key initiatives
we're working on for 26.
- Very exciting.
And I, you know,
honestly, I think, for me,
the biggest takeaway was just the fact
that you invested in laying
the right foundation,
but realized that this
wouldn't yield value right off the bat.
But then continuing to stay the course,
leadership, investments, and all of that.
And then of course now,
sort of hitting stride.
So really inspiring story.
Thank you for sharing.
Jane, any final words or any tips
or advice for for the audience
before we close here?
- Before they drag us off stage,
and there's a zero on the...
No, I think,
my advice would just be tell
your story, be really clear
and tight on what your story is.
Tell your story over and over again,
and be really focused in
your story on the metrics
that matter to your broader organization.
- Fantastic, thank you very
much, thank you everyone,
I think we're right on time,
appreciate everyone's
time, thank you, Jane.
- Thank you, thank you so much.